let's go to our voicemail number two one
nine two david p you can call any time
of day and many people do call very very
late at night or early in the morning
the morning depending on what your life
schedule is here is someone who is not
pleased with my pronunciation of a
particular presidential candidates name
take a listen
david how's it going man this is michael
from missouri right i want to tell you
something i'm a little i'm a little
peeved with you about you pronouncing
someone's name wrong on the show I think
it's on purpose and I think it's very
disingenuous of you I think you know who
I'm talking today you pronounced her
name Tulsi Gabbard I think not it's
clearly Tulsi keep a beard okay I'm very
angry with you I do need you need you
need to start pronouncing your name
right or else I'm gonna keep calling
about this well listen I stand corrected
as I've mentioned before English is my
second language I did not learn English
as a baby because it's what I heard
around me my parents did not speak
English to me when I was a kid because I
didn't live in the United States I lived
in a spanish-speaking country so there
are it actually happens quite a bit that
people write in and they say David
you're not pronouncing this correctly
are not pronouncing that correctly
sometimes I don't know how people
pronounce their names so I stand
corrected and I do apologise to anyone
that was offended by anything that I've
ever said on the program I will even go
further if I've ever offended anyone
with something I've said on the program
I apologize to you
unquestionably and unflinchingly with
absolutely no preconditions whatsoever
we've got a great bonus show for you
today the NCAA has taken a major step to
allow student athletes to be compensated
sort of while they are college athletes
not for the athletics themselves but for
their likeness we will talk about that
we will talk about a taco truck that
served ice workers then apologized and
then apologized again and we will also
talk about the US House of
Representatives voting to recognize the
Armenian Genocide a story of much
interest to many in our audience
interest
got a bunch of emails about it all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show become a member at join pakman.com
to get instant access or become a patron
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
we will speak to you on the bonus show